Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's einen Kartoffelsalat, perfekt zum Grillen aber auch das ganze Jahr über,
ich liebe ja Kartoffelsalat!
Und der ist so ein bisschen speziell, der ist auf Kiki Art,
der ist lecker und einfach gemacht und hier habe ich jetzt auch schon eine Schüssel.
Ich möchte auch gar nicht so viel Geschirr verschwenden deshalb mache ich hier zuallererst
sozusagen das Dressing in dieser Schüssel und geb dann alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu.
Also es ist ein Rezept für Faule, da müsst ihr nicht soo viel spülen!
Und ich habe jetzt hier einmal - das ist das Wasser von den Gewürzgurken,
das dürft ihr niemals wegschmeißen, das ist soo lecker!
So komisch das auch klingt! Ich würd's jetzt nicht so trinken
aber für unser Dressing ist es optimal! Das gebe ich jetzt hier rein.
So und dann gebe ich auch schon Senf mit dazu. Falls ihr  euch wundert:
"Warum fängt sie jetzt sofort an? Wo ist die Zutatenvorstellung?"
ihr findet immer die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung. So!
(H: Infobox!)
In der Infobox!
So, hier habe ich Senf. Ich persönlich bin jetzt nicht soo der Senf-Fan aber in diesem Dressing
ist das ein Muss und es schmeckt auch nicht so - also man schmeckt's nicht so krass raus
aber es macht halt einen schönen Beigeschmack.
So! Was haben wir noch schönes?  Hier habe ich ein bisschen Essig, ich nehme heute Apfelessig.
Einfach rein.
Dann habe ich hier etwas Öl, ich persönlich mag Leinöl ganz gerne.
Ihr könntet auch zum Beispiel Rapsöl nehmen, Distelöl, das funktioniert auch alles wunderbar.
So, einmal rein. Und weil ich totaler Knoblauch-Fan bin, werde ich da jetzt noch eine Knoblauchzehe reinpressen.
So, natürlich Salz und Pfeffer.
So, ich weiß es klingt jetzt ein bisschen banal aber die meisten haben ja mein
Schwarzkümmelöl Video gesehen, die meisten kennen mein eigenes Produkt
und die wissen dass ich das tagtäglich einnehme für das Immunsystem, für die Gesundheit.
und jetzt fragen mich ganz viele: "Wie kann ich das denn in meinen Alltag integrieren, in mein Essen?"
Weil es ist ja Öl und Öl kennt man ja bekanntlich auch zum Essen. Das darf nicht erhitzt werden
aber heute wird ja nichts erhitzt und es passt wunderbar zu Kartoffeln
deshalb integriere ich jetzt einfach noch einen Schuss von meinem Schwarzkümmelöl in dem Rezept.
Das passt auch wunderbar und jetzt verrühre ich das Dressing miteinander,
also die ganzen Komponenten miteinander.
So und das war's im Prinzip vom Dressing.
Jetzt müssen die festen Bestandteile rein, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt die Kartoffeln.
Die müsst ihr vorher garen, das sind vorwiegend festkochende Kartoffeln.
Ich habe die schon vorgegart damit das Video auch nicht zu lang wird und ich werde sie
jetzt einfach mit meinem Wellenschneider durchschneiden, da könnt ihr einfach schauen:
möchtet ihr sie größer, möchtet ihr sie kleiner? Das ist komplett euch überlassen.
(H: Zeig mal den Wellenschneider!)
Da!
(H: Ich liebe das Ding!)
Ich liebe es auch weil alles in Wellen sieht leckerer aus!
(H: Ja ist wirklich so!)
Und es ist auch tatsächlich gut für Kinder geeignet weil die sich eben nicht so schnell schneiden können.
Also wenn ihr Kinder habt, die grad anfangen möchten in der Küche zu helfen - wunderbar dafür geeignet!
Ich verlinke euch natürlich wie immer alles in der Infobox.
(H: Und vor allem auch stabil!)
So, die Kartoffeln sind jetzt in der Schüssel, da gebe ich jetzt noch Gewürzgurken mit dazu
und ich übertreibe immer gerne weil ich liebe Gewürzgurken!
Also es ist echt ne Menge, ihr könnt es auch reduzieren.
Dann hab ich hier rote Zwiebeln.
Ihr könnt auch Schalotten nehmen, ich finde die beiden Varianten ein bisschen milder.
Und ich nehme ganz gerne Mais mit dazu aber jetzt nicht soo viel.
Und jetzt einmal schön kräftig umrühren.
(H: Pack ruhig ein bisschen mehr Mais dazu!)
Ja? Ah du bist ja so ein Mais-Fan, ne?
(H: Ja, volle Kanne!)
Ach komm, komm, komm!
Was soll der Geiz, was soll der Geiz?
(H: Du bist die beste!)
So der Hamza hat jetzt gesagt: "Mach doch noch Paprika rein!" weil Hamza liebt Paprika
und ich finde dann haben wir auch eine Ampel: was Gelbes, was Grünes und was Rotes, perfekt!
Und ich gebe da jetzt noch Schnittlauch mit dazu, ich habe jetzt nur getrockneten
aber frischer passt natürlich auch richtig gut! Einfach oben drüber
und jetzt muss der Salat ziehen, also je länger er zieht, umso leckerer wird's
es ist leider so! Ich bin auch immer sehr ungeduldig aber gebt dem Ganzen Zeit,
mindestens 3h. Ihr könnt es auch am Vortag vorbereiten, um so besser
dann habt ihr nämlich am nächsten Tag wenn ihr grillt keinen Stress und ihr habt schon einen Salat vorbereitet
und er konnte richtig gut durchziehen!
Ja, mehr habe ich heute nicht zu sagen Leute, das war ein echt kurzes Video!
(H: Das ging schnell rum!)
Das ging richtig schnell!
Ich find jetzt sieht er auch noch mal richtig gut aus Hamza! Guck, sieht richtig richtig gut aus!
So!
Ich schreibe euch wie gesagt alles ganz genau unten in die Infobox und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr mir
weitere Vorschläge gebt was wir machen können.
ich habe mir schon so eine ganze Liste erstellt, ihr seid ja immer so fleißig im Vorschläge geben!
Aber immer gerne, immer gerne aufschreiben, wir richten uns komplett nach euch!
Und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben gebt,
Hamza ist gerade fast umgefallen!
(H: *lacht*)
Ich hab's gesehen! Er so: A-aa!
Ne, ist noch gut gegangen!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
(H: Ich wollt's unbedingt noch aushalten!)